welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and HBO is The Last of Us explores
the horrifying hypothetical of a
cordyceps fungal infection overtaking
Humanity episode 2 of this series
introduces a new element to the fungus
that isn't present in the games they're
connected
more than you know
the fungus also grows Underground
long fibers like wires some of them
stretching over a mile
you step on a patch of cordyceps in one
place and you can wake a dozen infected
from somewhere else this line sets up
the final scene of the episode in which
Joel shoots an infected runner in
mycelia's snake out of the soil around
the host's fingers and then that same
patch of the fungus alerts a horde of
nearby infected now again this is not
the case in the games in which the
primary range threat of the fungus is
Airborne spores but the producers
confirmed spores will not be part of the
series in season one this is all
inspired by real world mycology that's
the study of fungi and in fact the
largest organism on planet Earth is a
single fungus in eastern Oregon
sprawling four square miles or 10 square
kilometers estimated to be at least 2
400 years old but with the show when
many of you ask me follow-up questions
like how does the fungus control remote
Runners and clickers that it's not
attached to in that moment is it
telepathic is it pheromone base or does
this mean the fungus has a hive mind or
a memory or a soul or intelligence also
is it capable of love and can I marry it
because I want to be kissed like that I
quickly realized that I was out of my
depth but I I began this year promising
that we would be doing more expert
breakdowns on new rock stars so here's
our first one of 2023 so we're gonna
break down how cordyceps really works
separate fact from Science Fiction with
an actual expert please welcome to the
channel Mycologist for the New York
Botanical Garden who studies the
systematics and evolution of gordyceps
fungi a real cordyceps expert Dr joao
ararujo all right thank you Eric for the
invitation would be a pleasure to talk
about cordyceps with you so tell us
about what kind of work you do so my
work is I'm a scientist and I'm based at
the New York Botanical Garden where I'm
a researcher and curator in mycology
and I I have been working and studying
cordyceps diversity and evolution since
2010 so it has been 13 years dedicated
in this fungi I've done all my PhD in
Masters and postdocs on on the subject
and my work is basically describe new
species of cordyceps so I travel across
the world in South America mostly
Brazilian Amazon Africa Asia and
collecting these insects uh that are
manipulated it has this cordyceps fruity
body coming out from their body and then
they bring them to the lab do microscopy
work and then DNA work then we compare
with other species to decide if they are
new species or not so that's the the
foundation of my work wow uh you have
such an interesting job and now more
relevant I think to people who who
watched a ton of TV than ever I would
say oh it's got to be very exciting for
you yeah it's really amazing to see
something that I have dedicated like so
many years of my life being a pop
culture now and everybody is talking
about and especially in the second
episode I was watching and they were
searching for a Mycologist oh that's my
job of your cordyceps on the microscope
so that's what I do in a daily basis
this would be you who's um who's
kidnapped by government agents to go out
tonight exactly yeah that was really
really amazing to see that on on the TV
and we had mentioned before we start
recording that uh you've also played The
Last of Us games on I did yeah so you're
very aware of this whole uh World
um now the so The Last of Us game as you
know uses a mutated strain of the
cordyceps fungus which the game
developer Neil druckman based on a
planet Earth documentary that showed how
the fungus Works in ants uh the HBO
series producers even considered opening
with this clip for the series before
they instead wrote this 1968 talk show
scene in which a scientist describes
fungi like cordyceps and how they can
affect our brain chemistry and um they
say while the fungi cannot survive in
body temperatures over 94 degrees
Fahrenheit the scientist goes on saying
what if for instance the world would
slightly get warmer saying that there's
a reason to evolve the gene mutate and
the fungus could become capable
burrowing into our brains and taking
control of millions of us billions of us
billions of puppets with poisoned Vines
permanently fixed I'd want you to find
goal to spread the infection to every
last human alive by any means necessary
and there are no treatments for this I
have to start here how plausible is this
scenario in real life no that's very
unlikely because cordyceps have been
evolving with uh their whole insect
hosts for over a hundred million years
ago so they have been developing all
this ability to infect the insect and
overcome the immune system establish
inside insect and fulfill the insects
with fungal hyphae and all that stuff
but preserving the ins the the insect
brain so it can still manipulate it
somehow because if destroy the brain it
would be destroyed so there's no
movement anymore so the insect would be
completely useless for the fungus and so
it has been evolving for millions of
years and then they're very specific to
Insects so especially the of your
cordyceps that money the the ant
Behavior make their zombies they're very
specific so one species of
osteocordyceps were in fact one species
of ant so they're really specific not
only insect but ants but not only ants
but and species so the level of
appreciation is really really high so in
order to jump from a a infecting an ant
and then becoming a mammal a human
parasite that would be required so many
genetic changes and the ability to
overcome the human uh the human immune
system which is completely different
from the from the insect in in many ways
so there would be so many changes
required that would be taken millions
and millions of years for these changes
to take place I I believe so I think
it's pretty just a scientific fiction
for for for the series that's pretty
comforting to hear thank you
also in fact humans and has causing lots
of deaths yeah but they're not able to
infect the brain you know we could have
ended it there you had to scare us
together yeah but most fungi are
beneficial to the to the humanity and
for the ecosystems so even the parasites
so they're they're bad for one
individual hand but when we talk about
ants we're talking about but not just
one individual but our super organisms
that are composed by millions of
individual units but they act as one
individual super organism as the whole
Colony wow okay um yeah because there's
some questions about specifically how
that works too but first I just I also
this may seem like a dumb question but
when the cordyceps infects insects like
ants
um do those insects aggressively attack
each other the way science fiction
zombies do or the way the infected
humans do in this show well actually
what we have seen in the lab uh the lab
I used to work with in when when I was a
PhD student I I was in charge of working
the cordyceps diversity and evolution
other colleagues were doing artificial
infections of cordyceps in the ends to
observe them in the lab so how they how
they would react to to the injection of
uh cordyceps on them and then they found
out uh Professor David Hughes at Penn
State so what's my PhD advisor and they
they figure out that they take about two
weeks to develop and then to cause
manipulation under laboratory conditions
so our estimation is that it takes about
two weeks to for since the infection to
the manipulation stage and once the ant
is infected so the fungus will develop
inside the the ant body as a east-like
cells so there are single cells like
Global cells spheres floating out inside
the insect and as the disease progresses
all these cells will multiply in
completely feel that the insect body and
after the insect is killed so the after
the transition and then they become
filamentous fungi that will then
organize themselves to create those
protein bodies that will shoot spores so
that's how they develop but uh answer
your questions so they don't become
aggressive but they they will abandon
their colony to seek for a optimal
location for the fungus to develop so it
is an altruistic insect that abandoned
The Nest to do to act in favor of the
fungal Fitness so it's acting for the
fungus that's why we call it zombie ants
I see so it's not so much that they're
attacking each other they're just a bit
clingy like hey guys
they have to leave the colony because if
the the fungus the that infected ant was
detected by the other colony members
that has something called social
immunity so all the other colony members
would attack that infected one to stop
the the spread of the disease so what
the fungi cordyceps specifically of your
cordyceph developed in this ability to
manipulate was to remove the ant from
the the the the nest before the other
lead mates recognized it as infected and
killed it so the the cordyceps could not
develop and complete the life cycle so
the strategy for the social immunity and
these defensive mechanisms inside the
ant colony was to remove the ant from
the nest and then place them in the
location that's ideal for the fungi to
grow this was a brilliant mechanism that
the evolution shaped so I think it's
pretty amazing how they do that yeah you
brought up something really interesting
with the fact that um that cordyceps has
evolved with this species of ants for
you know millions and millions of years
it seems like ants have even adapted a
behavioral response to deal with it
which is encouraging as well that every
every species finds a way to deal with
their problems yeah yeah but as I said
the court is said the official cordyceps
they infect the uh a few members of The
Colony even when we find uh many
infected ants in the same tree sometimes
in the dozens like 30 ants in a single
tree hanging on the leaves with
mushrooms coming out from their body
it's pretty pretty amazing to see that
it's like Christmas tree but instead of
balls hanging there are ants with
mushrooms
on that on that stuff so I see that it
has some horror side of the story The
Dramatics zombification of stuff which
makes it cool and easier to to spread
the word with the brother brother public
other than scientists and academics so I
think this is a pretty amazing system to
communicate science through through
these stories I agree um getting back to
the show we learned early on in this HBO
series that fungus is spread through we
think the food supply specifically a
Flour Mill in Jakarta Indonesia they and
they call it a perfect substrate can you
explain what a substrate is and whether
flour would be a good substrate to
spread a fungus like this on a mass
scale yeah well the quadriceps are
pretty specific to to insects and now
we're finding out that they are also
present in inside plants as in the
fights but to spread to the next holes
they have to produce the the fruiting
body and shoot the spores and then it
lands into a suitable host that the
sport will germinate penetrate the
cuticle which is like the the the insect
skin analogous and then they penetrate
and then they they infect the whole
insect so I I don't think the the flower
would be would be too dry to start with
because fungi requires uh humid but
perhaps they they said it was the
perfect media for the Thunder to grow
because sometimes we go with bro fungi
on petri dishes
so which is it's like flour it's very
nutritionally rich like flowers are but
flour is completely dry so it would need
some humidity for the Thunder to thrive
and start to decompose that organic
matter yeah so but they are very
specific to insects and flower wouldn't
be the the perfect place for them to to
grow yeah I think it would be more of a
worst case scenario substrate like if it
were like it's some kind of sci-fi
scenario because just because flower is
just so widespread across the world yeah
and it's dry so fungi requires humidity
to to germinate spores to establish in
the substrate and do their their fungal
stuff so they need humidity now a grim
solution gets proposed on the show uh
enacted to control the spread of these
infections bomb start bombing and the
later we see a bomb crater in the city
of Boston and they say that you know it
worked in Boston
um but it didn't work in most other
cities why would bombing or fire be a
way to stop a fungus like this would
could that risk spreading more spores in
the real world well it wouldn't be
anyhow just like throwing a bomb and
destroying the whole season is already
something we we should not even discuss
uh in in any context even in a fungal
apocalypse so to start with yes but well
I think because fungi are difficult to
treat when the fungal infection and
stuff and so I think it's pretty hard if
that scenario was real so this fungi is
spreading to others and to others and
that would be crazy but for cordyceps
they would require to kill the holes
first
so the human would have to need to be
killed by the cordyceps and then days
later the fruiting body would come up
and then shoot spores to spread so that
would be enough time to see someone that
was dead but not with a fruity body so
we before the fruiting body it's formed
it cannot be transmitted well cordyceps
in the real life but who knows in the
the movie yeah yeah it sounds like this
is just kind of a drastic last Last
Resort
um yeah uh but I am so glad you guys
in any case we should never jump to bomb
yeah that's insane so also as you know
from playing the game Airborne spores
are a threat you have to wear an oxygen
mask uh the HBO show comes up with a new
form of a range threat the soil itself
which can contain what they say are
these fibers that extend for Miles
beneath the ground and alert other
patches of the fungus and the character
test explains this we see rows of
infected people on the ground reacting
to sunlight they all kind of roll over
in a wave pattern can uh you offer any
insights on what might be going on here
yeah well that was fictional completely
fictional I think they wanted to convey
the idea of uh Colony so that they will
act collectively against environmental
conditions or in response to
Environmental conditions but well in in
cordyceps of your cordyceps that in fact
ends and change their behavior so a true
zombie fungus so in one example in
Brazilian Amazon the species called
osteocordyceps nephophyoidis so these
species the asexual stage when they they
infect the ants they manipulate them to
go to the tree and when the the ant is
dead it's skilled by the fungus to the
tree so this fungi rather than only
producing the fruiting body they produce
like structures that look like roots and
they grow underneath the the Moss where
these ants are attached so they grow
underneath the these Moss carpet and
then they Roots a little bit wider than
the ends like a radius like like these
eyes and then when the other workers
come to see that that end is also
infected by a cordyceps then they they
will remove it from the tree to avoid
infection but one of those structures
that are growing underneath the moth
what they do is to keep the cordyceps
there and eventually they can grow a
small asexual structure that will
produce a spores and even though the
host was removed those filaments are
rooted underneath the Moss are producing
spores so there is a few examples where
they can produce similar structures like
that and and and creep through the the
the the the substrate but I I I don't
know any example of uh different
individuals are communicating and
transporting nutrients among each other
but it can be possible are fungi known
for having
um responses to light or temperature
increases or decreases yes there is a
very interesting fungus it's very
decently related to cordyceps called
Pilobolus so it actually grows on on
dung call Dung and when they grow their
their fruiting body they're really
beautiful translucent structures and
then they have a Global's head with a
dark like a little hat and then they
they pointed towards the light as just
because they need to shoot to the open
air so they they they they aim towards
the lights to have the Spore shot and
then when they mature they created such
a strong pressure and then these uh
spreading will be shot in very very high
speed if I'm not wrong this was uh
ranked at the mo the the the fastest
organism on Earth the speed this
speranging reaches it's super high like
a shotgun so it's faster than most
things in a while wow um yeah and
speaking of the speed of the version of
quarter steps of the show you know these
infected Runners get activated and they
take off running and they seem to know
where to go uh and so I want to ask you
in nature in real life can uh cordyceps
stay communicated with pieces of itself
once those pieces are no longer
physically connected like do pieces of
fungi or spores have possibly a memory
can they be directed by things like
pheromones what do you think no no no
they they no no absolutely not but the
the pheromones we we know very little
about that but they in some species
there are some studies showing that the
the manipulation in a different group of
fungi the antonym after or mycota which
is a very strange name so it's a
decently related cordyceps but some
species also have the behavior
manipulation thing and there was was
shown that they they when they they they
kill the holes and they start producing
the fruiting body they also release uh
pheromones that will mimic pheromone of
insects to attract other uninfected
insects and when they touch this
infected insects they get infected as
well because they try to mate with that
uh insect cover with fungal spores so
they that's how they are transmitted
there are some interesting strategies
right that is very interesting and like
when you know human audiences is human
audiences yeah when when people watch
this uh watch these science fiction
shows I think we often will project our
own kind of behavior onto inanimate
things like that's just human nature to
see personalities and souls and and
faces and things that may not be there
it's just a Natural Evolution at work
um and this moment I don't know about
you when I watched it I was like my mind
just jumps to oh it's hive mind it's
Avatar there's cognition among among
these um uh among this fungus
um and uh talking with our behind the
scenes guy Berg he's really interested
in these subjects of what constitutes
cognition uh a mind intelligence
um I this might be a tough question but
do fungi think well they they they can
collectively react
uh to environmental conditions and
biotic and abiotic uh conditions for
sure so I think that's a way of
reacting in a smart way
against or in reaction to something else
so I think this is a type of
intelligence and if we think of
evolutionarily the we think about as you
say we used to untrouble on
tropomorphize or throw four more for
Scythe I forgot the word so we try to
bring it to the analogous to to the
humans so like uh especially about
evolutionary processes we we tend to
think oh the the cordyceps they just
decided to remove the end from The Nest
so they don't make decisions they don't
decide so this is a result of millions
and millions of years of of evolution
and experimenting so nature experiments
a lot so one lineage eventually produce
a metabolize that was able to hijack the
end's brain and this lineage was
successful and then the senior lineage
still tried in the forest and then they
speciate into many other species like
cordyceps there are thousands of species
of quarter steps and the ones that have
the ability to manipulate the host
Behavior are over 35 species but our uh
our estimates range from over 600 to up
to a thousand species so there are lots
of different species just waiting to be
described yeah uh that's I mean again
just the the real the reality of it the
real scientific truth is just far more
interesting than I think what my
imagination jumps to this got me
thinking you know human beings we have
our own kind of self-centered way of
looking at this we think we have a mind
we have a soul we have a personality and
identity and memories uh is there any
kind of like Collective memory that can
exist among uh fungus colonies that uh
that is I don't know we might be out of
our depth here but might be more
advanced than the way human beings work
individually well yeah not exactly in
fungus but in Sly modes which which were
traditionally in the past considered
within the fungus these slime modes
actually those uh yellow thing the the
diaspora in in this type of of Sly mode
so they there are some studies really
really interesting showing that they
have some type of memory they can solve
puzzles in order to get food for example
and to get this nutritional stimulant
that they give them so they act
collectively in order to drive that that
Sly mode the uh shape amoeba shape into
this food source and which I I think is
is pretty pretty amazing for uh
unicellular organisms that they they act
uh collectively and and when they are
producing the fruiting body they're a
reproductive structures they form those
stalks to elevate those structures the
score engine and those stalks are
composed by by cells that committed
suicide in order to make that that uh
Stipe really rigid and able to erect
that that structure in order to shoot
spores more effectively so it's pretty
unaltruistic altruistic each particular
cell each particular nuclei will act
collectively but at the same time they
will perform also individual tasks like
suiciding in order to elevate the the
The Spar producing structure so there
are so many cool stories to be to be
told and we know so little about
especially cordyceps so there's very few
people studying their diversity and
their evolution in the world because
they are globally distributed and way
more people should be studying them and
trying to tell these stories because
there's so much more stuff we don't know
just sitting in the forest waiting for
us to go there and tell the story so
when you play a game like Last of Us or
watch the HBO adaptation uh as a
scientist who is an expert in this stuff
do you enjoy it um is it this uh do you
think it's performing a public good to
sign a spotlight on this area absolutely
absolutely I think it's pretty pretty
some some a few colleagues I see them
commenting on like in the picky way how
to oh this is not scientifically
accurate they should do it this way that
way so but just the fact we're sitting
here discussing cordyceps in in your
channel that is has super high uh
audience a lot of people pay attention
to that the National Geographic BBC
forums magazine and all these places are
discussing that in the last week so just
by discussing core deception the
importance and then there is a fungus
that hijack the host brains and produce
those fruiting body and they are
extremely photogenic so it it's easy for
us to spread the word about this fungi
but this is really amazing that the
series is taking this to another level
and communicating to millions and
millions of people so I think this is
just fascinating way to communicate and
Link the scientific work with the
science fiction the society and then the
broad public I think this is amazing
should and be done more and you know um
yeah as we mentioned earlier there is a
beauty there is a natural beauty in the
way that
um that these uh fungi Bloom and spread
outward and and form these stalks and
you know in the show it's a form of
environmental Terror but like in another
way the fact that we have to live with
them so much it kind of just creates
like this differently beautiful world
yeah and there's such a tiny structure
it's like the searching for a a needle
and a haystack in the forest because
imagine a Amazon rainforest so it's
really complex dense and lots of things
growing so and they occupy very specific
needs in the forest like underside of
rocks or inside tree trunks or other
side of leaf so you have to know what
you're looking for but once you
calibrate our eyes you can find lots of
them everywhere and but they are small
once they we bring them to the land or
even when we take photos with their
micro camera as as I show you some of my
photos and then they reveal to be much
more beautiful because they then we see
their details and their shapes and their
colors so I think this is a really
interesting group of organisms to make
this bridge between science
communication and sci-fi and the actual
hardcore science scientific work but I
think this is this is great Joel thank
you so much for breaking down
Alaska's for us it was so great to be
able to talk to a real-life cordyceps
expert working at the New York thank you
thank you so much so new rockstars is
covering the last of us with in-depth
episode breakdowns and after shows
subscribe to new rockstars And subscribe
to our new channel the Deep dive
launching February 17th you can follow
me on Instagram and Twitter at eat a
boss thank you for watching
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]